so einen Tag vor der nächsten deutschen
ESC Blamage stellt sich die Frage was
können wir überhaupt noch ich kann es
ihnen sagen quälende Kompromisse da
macht uns wirklich keiner was vor Bestes
und aktuellstes Beispiel der
flüchtlingsgipfel im Kanzleramt Olaf
Scholz am Mittwoch ganz alleine gegen 16
Länderchefs die alle sein Geld wollen
Showdown
Showdown übrigens um unser Geld ne für
den Bürger ist es ja eher wumpe was Bund
Land oder kommunenzahlen es bleibt
steuerkohle sechs Stunden am Stück Zopf
sechs Stunden haben die sich gestritten
der Kanzler heißt es will erst gar
nichts geben und findet dann plötzlich
doch noch eine Milliarde
in einem alten Mantel oder so keine
Ahnung
ich hoffe ich hoffe die Kommunen waren
angemessen dankbar die Ergebnisse des
flüchtlingsgipfels sind bei den Kommunen
auf Kritik gestoßen kommt wirklich sehr
viel Kritik heute morgen die Kommunen
sind enttäuscht sich ein bisschen in
Grenzen nur ein Tropfen auf den heißen
Stein und da sagen jetzt viele das ist
ein Schmalspur Kompromiss und insofern
bin ich natürlich besonders zufrieden
einer fand es gut so keine schlechte
Quote das eigentliche Problem nämlich
die langfristige Finanzierung der
Versorgung und Unterbringung von
Flüchtlingen wurde vertagt auf November
seit Monaten schlagen Landkreise Alarm
weil sie am Limit sind und wenn ich gar
keinen Wohnraum habe und gar keine
Kitaplätze hilft mir Geld sowieso nicht
gut dafür
hat die Runde im Kanzleramt beschlossen
dass asylprüfungen bald hauptsächlich in
Italien und Griechenland stattfinden
also muss jetzt noch irgendwer den
Griechen und Italien erklären aber das
findet sich Olaf Scholz ist nämlich was
total praktisches aufgefallen
in Europa ist umgeben von vielen anderen
europäischen
Mitgliedstaaten unserer Union und ist
deshalb ein Land das interessiert ist an
einem effizienten Grenzschutz der aber
anderswo stattfindet
ja Entschuldigung anderswo ist optimal
dafür
die Idee ist Asylbewerber mit geringen
Chancen auf Anerkennung kriegen schon an
der Außengrenze ja eine Art
Schnellverfahren und werden dann bei
Ablehnung direkt von da zurückgeschickt
wir fokussieren uns also auf die mit der
Bleibeperspektive was vielleicht sogar
Sinn macht wenn echte Integration
gelingen soll unser BAMF kommt
schließlich wissen sie gar nicht mehr
hinterher mit den vielen Anträgen ja die
sind total überlastet deshalb schnellere
Verfahren irgendwo draußen völlig neue
Ansatz oder das ist auch richtig wenn
man versucht die Asylverfahren direkt
dann beim Grenzübertritt durchzuführen
und versucht durchzusetzen und es hat
überhaupt nicht geklappt wie wir wissen
genau
genau genau und deswegen machen wir das
jetzt noch mal genauso aber wir sagen
diesmal die Idee wäre von Nancy fazer
genial oder voll clever voll clever und
ist ja auch nicht so dass die Nancy hier
sich da gar keine Mühe gegeben hätte sie
musste zum Beispiel in dem alten
Konzeptpapier von Horst Seehofer das
Wort transitzen drin mit
ankunftseinrichtungen überkleben ist
auch Arbeit plus ein paar ja kosmetische
Änderungen
bisschen Glitter drüber fertig ne man
muss sich auch nicht jedes Mal ohne Not
kaputt Arbeiten fakt ist seit 2015 kann
sich die EU nicht auf eine gemeinsame
Asylpolitik einigen für Flüchtlinge sind
in Europa grundsätzlich die anderen
zuständig ja genau
ohne einen Verteilschlüssel mit dem sich
die Europäer die Aufgabe endlich
verteilen werden Italien und
Griechenland garantiert nicht mitmachen
bei unserer neuen Ideen mit der
Außengrenze immerhin arbeitet man an
migrations bekommen das heißt Länder
nehmen Menschen zurück und Kriegen im
Gegenzug unter anderem legale
einwanderungsmöglichkeiten das ist eine
gute Idee könnte der gamechanger sein
aber warum fängt die Ampel damit jetzt
erst an oder wollen wir am Ende wirklich
nur noch Zäune bitte man sagt gar nicht
mehr Zäune ich glaube das und Kontrolle
herzustellen auch der physische Schutz
der Außengrenze in Betracht gezogen
werden muss eben niemand hat die Absicht
einen Sound zu bauen
was sagt man dazu also
keine Frage so wie bisher kann es auch
nicht weitergehen das ist survival of
the fittest also wer Geld für den
Schleuser hat kommt durch aber ich sag
mal gewisse rechtsstaatliche Standards
sollten wir schon noch einhalten auch
bei Asyl Schnellverfahren als nächstes
experimentiert die EU wohl mit noch
fixeren Methoden wo man direkt hinter
der EU-Grenze mit self-check-in Asyl
beantragt also wie bei McDonald's da
klickt man Asylverfahren starten und
dann kommen Fragen wie kommen sie aus
einem sicheren Herkunftsland ja Nein
sammeln sie Pushback Punkte und am Ende
muss er bestätigen dass er kein Roboter
ist klicken Sie alle Felder mit
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten an und
wenn man abgelehnt wird kommt wie würden
sie ja Asyl Erlebnis mit der EU beurteil
ne ja das ist wohl der nächste Schritt
so mancher ampelpolitiker argumentieren
jetzt wir brauchen striktere Asylpolitik
auch weil die AFD sonst abräumt ja 16%
bei forz gleich auf mit den Grünen ohne
dafür irgendwas zu leisten ohne eine
Lösung für irgendein Problem in
Thüringen steht die AFD jetzt bei 28
Prozent mit Abstand stärkste Partei
obwohl der Landesverband vom
Verfassungsschutz als erwiesen
rechtsextrem eingestuft wird geführt von
Bernd höcke den man den man laut
Gerichtsurteil Faschisten nennen muss er
darf man hat mich zum Teufel der Nation
gemacht obwohl ich vielleicht sogar das
Gegenteil bin ich muss mit diesem zerbit
Leben
und
verfolgt so Vorschlag meinerseits bevor
jetzt bürgerliche Parteien wieder aus
Angst vor der AFD Politik machen die AFD
WLAN gefällt was noch nie funktioniert
hat lassen wir ihn doch lieber Thüringen
regieren ja wenn die AFD nicht verboten
wird muss man Thüringen vielleicht
faschistisch werden lassen klar fürs
deutsche Image super optimal aber wenn
das da so viele wollen und es gehen wir
mal frischer Wind ins Fernsehen
hier ist das zweite thüringische
Fernsehen ZDF
guten Abend
herzlich willkommen zur tönenden
höckeschau Erfurt Thüringens
Ministerpräsident Bernd höcke
strategisches Genie und geliebter
Landesvater hat heute in einer
Pressekonferenz bekannt gegeben auch als
afd-kanzlerkandidat anzutreten er
kündigte an die afd-werte bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl nicht nur mit 28
Prozent über die Ziellinie laufen
sondern werden mit 33 Prozent plus X
über die Ziele laufen das muss unsere
Zielsetzung sein später präzisierte er
das Ziel sogar irgendwo zwischen 33 und
45 Prozent
Erfurt Thüringens sprachministerin Erika
Steinbach hat heute per Verordnung
festgelegt der Vocal Kampfbegriff
Schnitzel ungarische Art ist ab sofort
verboten Gerichte mit Paprika Schlotze
dürfen nicht mehr ohne das Wort [__]
im Namen angeboten werden oder auf der
Schokokuss trägt wieder seinen korrekten
Namen nach einem alten höcke Zitat heißt
er nun
lebensbejahender afrikanischer
ausbreitungstyp Kuss
Erfurt Ministerpräsident Bernd höcke
öffnete heute feierlich die neue
Gaspipeline Nord Stream 3 von
Wladiwostok nach Weimar Stargast der
Feier war der amerikanische
unterhaltungssänger Michael Wendler er
sang seinen größten Hit sie liebt den
Putin
nun noch eine Meldung aus Erfurt
Ministerpräsident und Sexgott bernd
höcke hat heute offiziell eine Koalition
der AFD mit der Union im Bund
ausgeschlossen wörtlich sagte er und so
steuern wird Philosoph kann man
besonders gut erkennen das ist diesem
Land vor allen Dingen an einem fehlt
aber wir bringen diesem Land dieses eine
zurück nämlich an Männlichkeit
[Applaus]
aber wenn man wenn während
doch nun zum Sport neuerdings mit Oliver
Welke er ist wie Sie wissen wegen
jahrelanger System nottigkeit zum
sportansager degradiert worden ja genau
hallo der Sport in der Nähe von Erfurt
gegen heute das legendäre Radrennen Tour
de Thüringen zu Ende mit einem
triumphan-sieg für Radprofi Bernd höcke
den wohl größten Athleten unserer Zeit
mit weitem Abstand führt er das
Teilnehmerfeld an der ist quasi der
Führer des Feldes großartig
gut ich hätte hier sonst noch ein paar
Meldungen vom Fußball allerdings sehe
ich gerade ganz ohne Bernd höcke soll
ich die trotzdem
das Wetter
wunderschön genau richtig für die
Jahreszeit und in keinem Fall Menschen
gemacht und nun wie jeden Abend im ZDF
viel Vergnügen mit den Filmen Winnetou 1
Winnetou 2 Winnetou 3 sowie Winnetou und
das Halbblut appanachi nimm das
burgistan Gute Nacht
[Musik]
vielen Dank
so meine Damen und Herren übermorgen ist
es soweit Wahlen im Unrechtsstaat aber
genug von Bremen
lassen Sie uns über die Türkei sprechen
eine Sensation liegt in der Luft die
Erdogan Dämmerung eine mögliche Abwahl
von Recep Erdogan steht sein
Regierungspalast ab nächster Woche
vielleicht schon bei Immoscout ja
da wünsche ich dem Nachmieter jetzt
schon viel Spaß bei den Nebenkosten tja
doch Vorsicht noch ist nichts
entschieden und selbst reden hat der
Mann noch euphorische Anhänger
erdogan ist der einzige außer ihm gibt
es niemanden für mich erst kommt Gott
dann kommt Erdogan einen solchen Führer
hat das auf dieser Welt noch nie gegeben
Mensch
da war doch für jeden was dabei
so in fast allen relevanten Umfragen
liegt Erdogan hinten aber wird er eine
Niederlage auch akzeptieren dass die
große Frage mein sicher wenn man sich
einmal dran gewöhnt hat auf extrem
geschmackvollen goldsesseln zu sitzen in
so einem Palast dann
wieder zurückgehen auf Ikea das hat ne
entsprechend angespannt das Nervenkostüm
des Titel Verteidigers vor allem wenn er
über seinen Herausforderer Kemal Kilic
storolo redet
geh mal trink so viele Bierfässer wie du
willst das wird Dir auch nicht helfen
mein Volk wird mein Platz nicht einem
Säufer überlassen
von Gerd Schröder gar nicht denkbar
gewesen
hinter den Säufer dem Sultan geht die
Düse denn sechs Oppositionsparteien
haben sich zusammengetan um ihn zu
entmachten sollte das klappen sagt
Erdogans Innenminister wäre das ein
Zitat vom Westen gesteuerter Putsch ja
oder
oder halt einfach Demokratie ne man soll
das ist wichtig nicht zu früh träumen
aber möglicherweise scheitert der Boss
vom Bosporus an diesem freundlichen
Gemüse Influenza es ist ein Mann mit
seiner Zwiebel der den türkischen
Präsidenten zu Fall bringen könnte
wenn Erdogan bleibt dann wird diese
Zwiebel bald 100 Lira Kosten
ja das Video ist viral gegangen
daraufhin hat Erdogan die Zwiebel
verhaften lassen er ist er ist wirklich
nervös kindisch Sozialdemokrat und alle
weg hat versprochen die Spaltung in der
Türkei zu überwinden das wäre mal was
Neues nach 20 Jahren Erdogan scheint
also ein guter Mann zu sein ruhig
ausgeglichen und sehr geduldig selbst
wenn man ihn im deutschen Fernsehen
beleidigt sie gelten als besonnen und
wurden von einer Finanzzeitschrift gar
zum Bürokraten des Jahres gekürt sind
sie der Olaf Scholz der Türkei
das zu fassen spinnt die denn
Scholz sie den Mann ohne Not an das
gibt's doch gar nicht eng wird für
Präsident Erdogan nicht zuletzt wegen
der Inflationsrate über 40 Prozent da
kommst du mit dem Geld drucken kaum noch
nach es ist tatsächlich dramatisch aber
wie weit geht er wenn in die Wähler
dafür abstrafen wenn allein die
Möglichkeit einer Niederlage ist ja für
recept außerhalb seiner
Vorstellungskraft im Moment versuchen
seine Berater wohl ihnen ja ganz
behutsam man das Thema verlieren
heranzuführen mit einfachen spielen wie
zum Beispiel Kniffel
ja Kniffel
[Musik]
geht doch sehr schön gut angefangen hat
er ja mal tatsächlich als demokratischer
Reformer aber spätestens mit den
gesi-protesten begann die Umschulung zum
Diktator und die hat echt gut geklappt
aktuell sitzen immer noch 39
Journalisten in türkischen Gefängnissen
ja sogar im Ausland macht Erdogan jagt
auf politische Gegner schandünder z.B
muss in Deutschland rund um die Uhr von
LKA Beamten beschützt werden warum nimmt
unser Staat das klaglos hin ernsthaft
andererseits allein die Tatsache dass
ich der Sultan überhaupt noch Wahlen
stellt ist er erstaunlich seine
Autokraten whatsapp-gruppe lachen sie
ihn dafür schon aus ne da hat eben z.B
Putin neulich geschrieben was bitte ist
eine Opposition zwinker Smiley kim Jong
und schickt Erde nur die loser Geste
Lust Raketen emoji und dann fragt Papst
franziskus okay Leute wer hat mich zu
dieser Gruppe hinzugefügt
gute Frage ich was nicht aber wer weiß
wer weiß vielleicht hat Herr Erdogan
einfach nur Angst vor dem Pensionsschock
der berühmten verrentungsdepression der
soll sich mal coachen lassen sage ich am
besten von einem erfahrenen Best Ager
aktiv bleiben im Ruhestand Tipps für die
desputenrente mit gernotasknecht
chill doch mal schalten Gang runter oder
bist du jetzt der nächste wütender alte
Sack der nicht weiß wann Schluss ist
machs lieber wie ich man kann auch als
Rentner anderen Menschen das Leben zur
Hölle machen sie an den kleinen Dingen
erfreuen wenn zum Beispiel beim Nachbarn
Kindergeburtstag ist ruf ich um 15 Uhr
die Polizei oder wenn irgendwo eine süße
Katze spielt
solche Sachen und du hast doch alles
erreicht als das Boot die Türkei liegt
in Sachen Pressefreiheit auf Platz 165
kurz vor Nordkorea das hast du geschafft
klar gibt's da draußen immer noch ein
paar Journalisten die frei rumlaufen
aber irgendwann muss man auch loslassen
sei stolz auf deine Erfolge nicht nur
als Autokraft auch als Humorist Alter
was habe ich mich weggeschmissen bei
deinem letzten Bühnenprogramm wir als
die Türkei fordern Europa auf die
Menschenrechte und die Demokratie zu
respektieren
hier dieser andere super lustige Moment
als du die von der Leyen aufs Katzen zu
vergesetzt hast und sie so ähm
bleibt noch zu erwähnen dass die
EU-Kommission darauf verwies dass Ursula
von der Leyen vom Sofa aus lange mit
Erdogan über Frauenrechte diskutiert
habe und während du um deine Söhne immer
reicher werden wird die Bevölkerung
immer ärmer will sagen in einer
gerechten Welt kämst du direkt aus dem
Palast in den Knast wird nicht passieren
also geh wenigstens geräuschlos in Rente
wie gesagt man kann auch zu Hause
Menschen unterdrücken die eigene Familie
zum Beispiel dafür hat man die doch
angeschafft
bitte
rausgestellt
[Applaus]
in die heute-show
ich mach dir gleich eine Live Seite in
die neue Show heute
oder was
ich sehr gut Scheiße
aktiv bleiben im Ruhestand Tipps für die
des Guten Rente mit germotasknecht
[Applaus]
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen